you
hi everyone is Jerry the Rubinstein trap
is a trap for white out of the Queens
gambit declined how it works exactly is
to have these three Queen side pieces
eventually converging on the c7 square
here's how it works
after d4 d5 c4 e6 the Queens gambit
declined we have now what follows a
group of developing moves a group of
logical moves for both sides or in other
words minor pieces getting out getting
castled getting rooks to half open files
so Knight c3 Knight f6 white pins the
knight black breaks the pin III black
castles and after a couple Knight moves
we have a very common position one that
could come about from a different move
order and before Bishop d3 is played the
tension between these two pawns is first
resolved so C takes D e takes D and only
then Bishop d3 rook to e8 logical enough
half open file and white doing similar
along the C file sensing pressure
against the c7 pawns c6 is very common
ruling out any possibilities for Knight
b5 to maybe converge on the c7 square as
well as just reinforcing the center on
d5 after now castles we have h6 throwing
a question to the bishop and more
long-term providing a flight square for
the King even though at the moment it is
being guarded after Bishop f4 the trap
has been set and it's one that can very
easily catch black the side who may very
well be aware of this idea of the bishop
pair being very good in a chess game or
in other words trying to get a knight
for Bishop exchange in this instance
here it's faulty running after this
Bishop pair in this case right here with
Knight to h5 looking to get that dark
square Bishop runs into the tactic of
Knight takes on d5 knowing full well
that if pawn takes Knight Bishop c7 the
queen is dead she has no squares
black can of course bail out at this
moment right here and not take the night
and instead night takes f4 but note that
the night can sidestep the pons threat
and just recapture on f4 and after the
smoke has cleared white is up upon an a
very significant one at that being that
it is a central pun and white clearly
stands better
you